welcome to hannity all right buckle up
tonight because we have a jam-packed
show
new york governor andrew cuomo facing
yet another massive scandal we'll bring
you the very latest details straight
ahead
as the left likes to say well the walls
are now
closing in on andrew cuomo these walls
well pretty interesting they were all
built by the democrats
not republicans also tonight mitt romney
admitting president trump will be the
2024 nominee if he decides to run
laura trump she'll react tonight with a
full preview of the president's upcoming
speech this weekend at cpac
but first breaking today in what must be
totally humiliating to joe biden
we now have dozens of house democrats
not republicans calling on joe biden to
relinquish
his sole authority to the nuclear codes
you know the nuclear football in a
letter the democratic lawmakers state
quote
vesting one person joe biden with this
authority
entails real risks now first of all
it's unconstitutional that's first of
all there's one commander-in-chief
it is not the u.s congress there is zero
constitutional ambiguity here
but second of all what do these
democrats know about
joe biden that maybe the rest of us
don't
they didn't propose this even when
donald trump was president
and they all hated donald trump
obviously from our own
observations as we have been saying and
it's interesting many liberals and even
occasionally when i see people in the
media mob and they
are trying to act polite with me they'll
privately say yeah
we're all on pins and needles every time
joe talks
because we can all see with our own eyes
if you compare joe biden to four years
ago ten years ago
he's frail he's weak and he's struggling
cognitively
now if he ever had a fastball i would
argue it's long gone
and let me also be clear i'm not making
any medical
diagnosis about joe biden
and this is not about his age for
example bernie sanders
is a year older than joe biden he has
way more energy
way more stamina way more mental
alertness
fighting every day for his insane
socialist utopia
donald trump similar age boundless
energy
and alertness joe biden always seems
like he needs a nap
he also frequently confuses numbers
dates
and sometimes you know can barely get
the words out
take a look the idea that um
over 500 [ __ ] i have a card i carry a
card with me every day
with the total number of folks who have
been affected fully vaccinate 300
americans
by end of the summer the beginning of
the fall
but we want to make look that's i want
to repeat
it'll be enough to fully vaccinate 300
americans
to beat this pandemic 300 million
americans
going this way thank you all i got in
trouble when we were running against
the senator who was a mormon the
governor
okay we hold these truths to be
self-evident
all men and women created by the goal
you know the you know the thing
this isn't about a few gaffes look he
reportedly goes to bed
very very early he has few public events
his vice president
kamala harris has been making a lot of
news
is taking a lot of solo calls with world
leaders on behalf of joe
a little odd in and of itself and he
never misses any opportunity
whatsoever to call an early lit on the
day
in other words we won't be seeing a
hearing from the president for the rest
of the day it's 8 a.m
or canceling trips recently took a snow
day
after the white house got a whopping two
inches of snow
on the campaign trail he barely had any
public events at all
he cowered in his basement bunker the
media mob
big tech they shielded him from any and
all negative stories
and pretty much campaigned on his behalf
and went out trashing his opponent
every second of every day we called it
on this program the candidate protection
program
and it was to be honest pretty effective
one poll conducted after the election
showed that
one in six biden voters would have
changed their minds
had they known the full details about
biden's various scandals
including the yes very true hunter biden
laptop story from the new york post
but now joe biden is president and
democrats are apparently so worried
about his ability to fulfill his duties
as commander-in-chief
they want him to hand over the nuclear
codes
remember this is not an isolated
incident just a few months ago as
president trump's term was coming to an
end nancy pelosi
remember she backed that bill that would
set up a nonpartisan commission to
determine
a president's fitness for office she
said the bill wasn't about donald trump
so what's who is the bill about
what did it all mean it really makes you
wonder what the democrats are thinking
about their own commander in chief